with song and dance South Africans
commemorate the life of one of the great
leaders of modern times thousands have
traveled to Nelson Mandela's former
residents in Soweto to pay last respects
to the father of the nation which is
growing up we weren't allowed to mention
his name a mom would always say tu hace
con men today we're going to get
arrested he Sokrates he liberated my
grandmother he liberated my grandfather
he made things easier once named enemy
of the state Nelson Mandela became south
africa's first black president in 1994
today he is celebrated as South Africa's
great healer throughout the country
books of condolence give people a chance
to put their thoughts on paper a sea of
flowers spreads out in front of
Mandela's home a sign of mourning and a
gesture of gratitude invite a spokesman
for Mandela's family expressed
thankfulness for the outpouring of grief
in South Africa and the world over this
once more underlies the simple truth
that Madiba was not just a citizen of
South Africa and the broader African
continent but a global citizen world
leaders and dignitaries will attend a
memorial service in Johannesburg on
Tuesday